Gabby esta and many of you have asked
how do you approach the work-life
balance is it better to spend more time
on work more time and family and I I
want to emphasize that you can have uh
the most of both I found in life that
when faced with the problem of two
things that seem mutually exclusive if I
was smart enough I could get 75 percent
of each and uh the key is to get more
out of a day if you can get more out of
a day
by leveraging yourself in a number of
ways you will get more life into a day
and so rather than thinking I have to
give up family or I have to give up uh
the work thing you could think Be Clever
think about how to combine them and like
in my case I I would you know bring my
kids through business work and or I
would also think about how I could get
leverage from others and work so the key
is increasing your efficiency in Your
Capacity to put more life into life and
then you can get more work and you can
get more
um my family life balance so squeeze
more in by understanding how to do that
I've covered a lot of that in the book I
can't cover it all here